bueno este es una declaratoria que se da
para permitir que los actores del estado
puedan coordinar mejor puedan tener
facilidades para actuar para atender
esta situación este desastre que estamos
viviendo por este derrame de petróleo
señora muñoz cuál es la magnitud del
impacto que puede causar en la de la
biodiversidad de esta zona de perú
bueno el impacto es enorme
lamentablemente la poca digamos el poco
sentido de urgencia que ha tenido la
empresa para atender esta situación y
sobre todo para reconocer la magnitud
del daño ha hecho que esto se extienda
muchísimo si se hubiera contenido
inmediatamente
tendríamos una zona menor afectada pero
lamentablemente como esto demoró en
hacerse lo que ha sucedido es que se ha
extendido y a pesar de que se ha
contenido el área se está tratando de
contener el oleaje la marea hace que se
vaya afectando una zona mayor
biodiversidad muchas especies de lobos
de peces tenemos una gran afectación en
playas 21 playas que están en este
momento cerradas las labores de limpieza
sin duda es una afectación enorme al
ambiente y además a muchos pescadores
que han perdido la oportunidad de tener
su medio de sustento de vida porque no
pueden seguir a pescar y esto está lo
decía esa crítica que no sólo hubo
información inexacta sobre la de
petróleo que se derramó sino una
respuesta tardía a la situación de quién
es la responsabilidad en todo este
desastre
en los temas ambientales existen lo que
se llama la responsabilidad objetiva el
que contamina paga'
no importa si finalmente esa empresa
como en este caso a repsol después de
las investigaciones aparece que no tenía
o tenía una condición un accidente pero
no hay que esperar que se haga la
investigación para que la empresa sea
responsable de atender toda esta
situación porque el cloro que se ha
derramado es el suyo por lo tanto ellos
están obligados de la de actuar para la
realización inmediatamente